TAD EINSTEIN: Welcome
to StratoZone,
the only way to start
your migration journey.
My name is Tad Einstein,
and I'm a senior program
manager with Google Cloud.
We also have Karl Koshy,
CEO of StratoZone here today
to talk about the
benefits of StratoZone
and how it will help you
accelerate your cloud journey.
One of the first
pieces that you want
to focus on when looking
to migrate to the cloud
is the assessment
and discovery phase.
Doing things proper early on
will yield amazing results
in the end.
So one of the first
pieces is to make sure
that your team is properly
educated on the cloud
and that your engineers
are ready to actually move
to the cloud once you
start the process.
So things like training
are critical in this space.
Also, you'll want to
focus on experimentation.
It's very important that they
get to break things in order
to understand how to get through
some very interesting cloud
paradigms during your migration.
And, also during the
assessment phase,
you need to catalog all
of your applications.
So we typically create
three buckets, those which
are easy, hard, and can't move.
But when doing this, how
do you go about sorting
your applications?
And also, how do you go
about picking a first mover?
In a typical enterprise,
there are many applications
which are interwoven.
So doing this step
properly is paramount
to a successful migration.
So as we discuss examples
of application sorting,
you can see that we have
those systems which might be
disconnected and non-critical.
This might be something
like a marketing website,
back up an archive, or death
test environment where you're
literally able to take them
from the current environment,
whether on premise
or another cloud
and lift and shift them into
Google Cloud very easily.
You'll also then have your
set of applications that
fall under what we call hard.
Those are things like
back office applications,
data analytics.
They're usually
non-critical, but they're
very interconnected.
So those might not be
the best first mover,
but they're perfect
for the cloud.
And you might want to do those
in a second or third way.
Then we also have those that
just cannot move to the cloud
that maybe running on legacy
hardware which just doesn't fit
in a cloud paradigm.
So what are the
business characteristics
of a good first mover?
Well, when you
think about it, you
want those applications
which are not
business critical and also
which are not edge cases.
You want to find
applications that
are stateless that, as
we've said previously,
can literally be
lifted and shifted.
And that makes a
great first mover
because it allows you to learn
the interworkings, not only
the cloud, but of the
migration process.
You also focus on apps that do
not require much refactoring
for your first movers.
It makes no sense spending a ton
of time having your developers
recode an app when there
are other applications
in your environment
that can quickly
be brought into the
cloud as you're working
through things like compliance.
Also, be aware of those
applications which
do have compliance challenges
or third-party proprietary
licenses.
When moving to the cloud
or any sort of migration,
you have to think
about cutover windows.
So when choosing
that first mover,
make sure it's an
application where
you can accept that
downtime to your business
so that when you
lift and shift, it's
not of significant
impact to the business.
And then most importantly,
throughout all
of these iterations,
you're going
to build a knowledge
base for your engineers
and for your team and for
your business as a whole
as it relates to
the cloud migration.
This is why it's critical to
find those right first movers
so that you can build a
knowledge base which you then
will build off of even further.
So Google's created a cloud
migration methodology.
And it consists of four stages.
The first, which we
just referred to,
is the assessment phase,
which is where you understand
what's currently in your
environment, how it connects,
and what would be
needed when you start
looking to move to the cloud.
Next, you have the
foundations phase.
And this is where
you actually set up
the cloud for the first time.
So what you do is you
create a landing zone.
You set up networking,
identity and access management,
security rules that
are in compliance
with what your company desires.
Once the foundation
is properly set up,
you can then go through
the migration phase, which
ensures that what
you're migrating
goes into an environment
that is properly sound based
on your company's objectives
and security model.
Finally, the last
phase is optimizing.
Once you've lifted and shifted
your applications to the cloud,
now you can start optimizing
and leverage cloud native
technologies to really benefit
from what the cloud breaks.
Now, I want to quickly touch
on the assessment phase
because this is often the
one where people get stuck.
And the reason why is
actually understanding
what's in your environment
can be very difficult.
Often, enterprises
have applications
that have spanned
upwards of 20 years.
And often the information
is not readily available.
By leveraging a
tool like StratoZone
you're able to easily deploy
their data collection utilities
within your environment,
collect the data of how
your applications interact,
review the analytics
and also optimize cloud strategy
of what those applications will
look like during the migration
and also create a business case
and road map, which
you can present
to your IT leadership
and corporate executives.
Now, the five needs to
create a cloud strategy are
to have a scalable and
non-intrusive discovery process
or assessment phase, which is
what StratoZone brings to bear
as well as the ability to define
cloud fit and suitability.
We discussed how not
every application
is a good fit for the cloud.
And by leveraging
StratoZone, you're
able to quickly understand
which one of those applications
might need to be
retooled or might not
be a fit also defining the
shared consumption plan.
So delivering a high savings,
a return on investment
within Google Cloud,
maybe understanding
that certain things that ran
in your on-premise environment,
you can adjust the
metrics of RAM CPU
to something a little less
and get significant savings
without a performance hit.
Also, defensible and
competitive financials.
So getting the information
that you're then
going to give to your CFO, to
your CEO that clearly defines
what your cloud strategy
is from a financial aspect
and what it looks like
over time and then also
a consumable roadmap.
Now that you understand
the financials,
now that you understand
what's going to move,
what does that look
like over time?
And how are we going to
get our entire organization
into the cloud?
So with that being
said, I'd like
to introduce Karl
Koshy, CEO of StratoZone
to talk more about
StratoZone and how
you can leverage it today.
KARL KOSHY: Thanks, Tad.
So we're going to spend a minute
talking about what StratoZone
delivers to the customer.
There are two levels
of deliverables.
First, we're talking
about the basics.
The first set of deliverables
is around financials,
business case, and roadmap.
So let's go through
some of those.
Number one, StratoZone helps
you to very efficiently discover
your environment.
This is an agentless
data collection process
that's very quick.
After this is done,
StratoZone will then
capture the customer
requirements
which it overlays on the
underlying data, thereby
helping to pick the
best fit products
and ultimately arrive at
what the goes where and when.
This is the crux of what
StratoZone delivers.
That includes a
delivery model which
could determine how
you consume cloud
is this infrastructure as a
service, platform as a service
and so on.
Or is something not meant to go
to cloud in your implementation
model?
So you decide in
your cloud model
such as your hybrid model, a
private, public, or otherwise
blended model that
you may want to use.
After this, the platform helps
you develop your business case,
create your adoption
roadmap, and then
also create a migration plan.
Some of the advanced
deliverables
include machine shaping,
optimization, roadmap modeling,
PaaS analysis, which is
platform as a service analysis,
and then most importantly,
dependency mapping.
This is an important
component of what customers
look for in their environment
to see what talks to what,
and how all of your
applications are related.
This is a very
critical component
needed when you decide this--
what of your environment
is going to move
first, second, last,
and also decide on
the timing for those.
With this, we'll go now into
how you can use StratoZone
and what the process looks
like to implement StratoZone.
So the first step in the
process is to register either
as a customer.
Or a partner can
register their customer
and gogcp.stratozone.com.
Once again, that's
gogcp.stratozone.com.
The customer then receives
one or more data collectors,
which are simple install
shield applications
that they will use to
install the application
in their environments.
It could be one
collector per environment
or one collector across
multiple environments.
This is the customer's choice.
The second step
in the process is
where the customer's
technical administrators
deployed the data collectors
after customizing it
to their needs.
This could include
deciding what IP ranges
they want to collect
upon or what environments
they want to collect upon.
Once that collector is
deployed within 24 hours,
customers, partners, as
well as your cloud provider,
can come up there
and take a look
and see what those
results look like.
This includes the analysis of
the environment, optimization
of assets, optimization
of your machine shapes
and how you would consume cloud,
as well as developing a roadmap
and moving on to the next
steps in your planning.
Now, the StratoZone data
collector is agentless.
It is all encrypted.
It's lightweight.
And most importantly,
customers can
decide what data
fields they want
to anonymous from within
their firewall that
reaches the StratoZone portal.
So this is a custom
anonymization ability
given to customers.
Let's take a second and
talk about data security
and the data that's collected.
The data that's
collected primarily
focuses on machine data--
things like performance,
installed application names,
network traffic,
processes and services
that are running in
the utilization of all
of these components.
What we do not collect is
user information or profiles,
any data that's underlying
the applications, anything
in your database
or file storage,
application configuration
files, for example,
or typically any
data that is subject
to any regulatory compliances.
All the data is encrypted
in transit and at rest.
And customers can
anonymize any data
they see fit from
leaving their firewall
and going to the
StratoZone portal.
TAD EINSTEIN: Thank you, Karl.
So as one of the
next steps for you,
you can actually start
your learning journey
with Google Cloud today and
most importantly, actually
get hands on with
StratoZone to run
through your own assessment
within a fully functional
Google Cloud environment.
To do so and take the
introduction to StratoZone
Assessment hands-on lab,
you can register for access
to Google Cloud
learning tools, one
of those being our
hands-on labs platform
Qwiklabs where you
can actually start
the exact lab for StratoZone
and leverage the functionality
that Karl spoke about today.
Prior to that, Karl will
go through a demo, which
will show how the
product is leveraged
and how you can benefit from
it for your cloud migration.
KARL KOSHY: Hello, everyone
and welcome to a demo
of the StratoZone platform.
This demo will be focused
on the basic assessment.
We will first walk you
through the process
of starting an assessment,
reviewing your assessment data,
and finally, generating a
report showing your cloud fit
and business case.
To get started, you will first
need to register your customer
at gogcp.stratozone.com.
When you do so, you will also
receive a separate registration
link via email.
Once you create your
username and password,
you'll be able to log in
at portal.stratozone.com
and get to this dashboard
that I'm looking at now.
So once you're here,
how does StratoZone
help you and your customer on
the cloud migration journey?
Well, we have two
different modules
associated with the assessment.
First is the Analyze module.
And this is where all of the
raw data from the environment
is collected.
It's also where we
review that data
and validate that it's the
complete set of migration
candidates.
The Analyze module
will also allow
you to create an
initial business case.
The Plan module is here for
more advanced price modeling,
as this allows you to do custom
groupings, custom right sizing,
and also select particular
VM instances per server.
So let's start with
the Analyze module.
Let's start with
When you first click
on the Analyze module,
you'll be presented with
the Analyze Dashboard.
In this dashboard, you can view
the total number of servers
collected into inventory.
You can view the
number of those servers
that are Windows
and Linux and which
ones are marked out of scope.
You can also view the total
virtual core count, the VRAM,
and the allocated storage.
In the bottom right here,
you can view the server age
distribution.
And in the top right, you
can view our StratoFit score,
which is a measure of
infrastructure cloud readiness.
Next, let's view
the Summary tab.
The Summary tab is still
taking an aggregate
of all customer servers.
However, it does allow you to
view some metrics that are not
available in the Dashboard tab.
For instance, you can view
the exact operating system
distribution of the customer
environment, as well
as that environment's
memory distribution.
In the bottom left, you can
view some basic asset statistics
about the environment.
And in the bottom right, you
can view the asset utilization
as a percentage of the
total allocated capacity.
On the left side toolbar, you
can view additional details
about the operating systems, .
storage, memory, server age,
and the installed software
within the environment.
Of course, you won't be able
to view this information
until the scan is
actually running.
To view the progress
of the scan,
access the Assessments
tab at the top.
After you click on
Assessments, you'll
be presented with your
different assessment groups.
In this example, we have a group
for East coast, West coast,
primary data
center, and anything
that's not Windows
or Linux, which
must be a manual asset entry.
As you can see, we have one
collector for each data center
location.
The general recommendation
is to have one per location.
But keep in mind
that the customer
can install more than one
per location if desired.
And any duplicate assets that
are scanned by both collectors
will be automatically
removed by the system.
Note that for each
collector, you
can check the status of the
scan as well as the server
count of the expected values.
For the status, it will either
say complete or installed
if it's been started.
Or it will say not
started if it has not
been installed and connected
to the web service.
After the collectors are
installed and configured,
you'll be able to view the
inventory as it comes in.
To do so, access the
Inventory tab at the top.
Now, that we have access this
specific server, at the top,
you can see all of the
basic configuration info.
This will tell you not only
what is the server name and IP,
but also whether it's a virtual
machine or bare metal, how
many CPU cores are allocated,
how much RAM is allocated,
what operating system
it's running on,
as well as the processor
of the host machine.
If you scroll down,
you can also view
graphs that outline
the performance data
or the utilization of each of
those components over time.
Similar to the Summary
tab, more information
can be accessed on
the left hand toolbar.
For instance, clicking
on the Storage tab
will allow you to view details
about the exact storage
partitions, what's
free, what's not.
If you click on Network, you
can view the exact network
configuration as
well as what subnet
that server is located in.
You can also view
running services
on that server, running
processes, installed software
if there are any, as well as
memory utilization metrics
and CPU utilization
metrics by process.
What I have just shown
you from the Inventory tab
represents all of the
configuration and performance
data that we have
collected from each server.
The last piece of
information that we have
are the network dependencies.
To view the network
dependencies,
click on the Dependency
tab at the top.
The Analyze
Dependency tab allows
you to view server-to-server
network dependencies
by selecting an
individual server.
To select that
server, you can do so
by accessing your
collector groups
and a specific collector.
Or you can just click on
Details on the left-hand toolbar
to view all available servers.
Once you've selected the
server that you want,
click on the eyeglasses
symbol to view it.
This will now provide you with
a graphical view of the network
dependencies, as well as a more
specific view in a table format
below.
As you can see, we're collecting
the protocol, source and target
IP, source and target port,
as well as the installed
app on the source machine.
All of this information
comes from a netstat command
and is included as part of the
agentless scan via StratoProbe.
One critical feature of
this tab is its ability
to detect on scan devices.
You can see an example
of this down here
where it says Unscanned Device.
If I expand that, you can
see the same netstat details
about that unscanned device.
You can also view that device
in a graphical format up here.
There is an Unscanned
Device button
that will bundle any
unscanned devices.
If you double-click that and
click this in the top right
and in the view, you can
see that there are actually
two distinct IP addresses.
Now, we have not
scanned these devices.
And so the only thing that we
know about them are their IPs.
But this is still, nonetheless,
useful for a scoping exercise
to ensure that all
target servers are
being included in the analysis.
The next tab we will look
at is the StratoFit tab.
The StratoFit tab is a
machine-level indicator
of cloud readiness.
It does not take into
account broader server side
application structure.
However, it does look at
each individual server
and determine based on that
service capacity and operating
system, whether it is ready for
a lift and shift to the cloud.
As you can see, the
StratoFit is represented
by three different scores--
low, medium, and high.
High are the easy movers.
These are the servers that are
already modernized and ready
for lift and shift.
Lows are anything that is
incompatible for the cloud
entirely.
Usually this is due to an
older operating system, say,
an old CentOS version,
like CentOS 4 or 5,
or Windows 2000/2003 that
are deemed incompatible
for the cloud.
The servers that
are flagged medium
are somewhere in
between where they
are technically modernized
enough for the cloud.
However, they tend
to have a higher
number of network dependencies
with other servers.
This means that they
are most likely involved
in some type of broader, more
complicated app structure that
may make it more
difficult to move.
If you would like
to investigate why
a particular server received
the score that it did,
you can do so on the left-hand
toolbar under details.
If you click on Details,
it will list out
all of the scored servers
from low to medium to high.
If you want to know
why a server received
a score other than
high, simply click
on the dropdown for that
server and view those reasons
in sentence format.
Note that the StratoFit score
has six different parameters.
You can customize how sensitive
each of these parameters
are on the left-hand
toolbar under Actions,
Customize Parameters.
If you click on
Customize Parameters,
you will see all six
of them listed out.
And you can adjust
the slider bar
to change the
sensitivity of each.
To finish up the Analyze
module, let's take
a look at the Reports tab.
Within the Reports tab,
it's important to note
that any of the information
contained in the Analyze module
can be exported as a report.
At the top are summary reports
which tend to be either slide
shows or PDFs.
At the bottom are
detailed reports,
which are essentially CSV
dumps of the raw information.
To generate an Executive
Summary Report slideshow,
create a summary report.
First, click on the
button for that,
then select the groups, whether
collectors or bill groups
that you would like to
include in the slideshow.
You can then select
your Baseline Vendor
Catalog, which we will usually
use the PRIVATE DATA CENTER.
Compare that to the
various Google catalogs,
name it, and click
Create Report.
After your report is
finished building,
you can download it
by clicking this icon.
Note that you can download
it as a Google slides
as well if you prefer.
Now, let's open this
up so we can take
a look at what is produced.
So for starters, it will produce
some introductory slides,
like a table of
contents, as well as
a background on the
overall assessment process.
It will also produce
a slide outlining
the different collectors
that were set up.
Then it's going to jump right
into the high-level findings.
So this is the
high-level configuration
here followed by some
more advanced metrics,
like the utilization
percentage in the bottom right
and then jumping into
the cloud readiness.
So this is the StratoFit score,
which is an infrastructure
cloud readiness score.
And we also have
a PaaS fit score.
So this is going to identify
any potential PaaS candidates.
After those high-level
findings, we'll
show the financial comparison.
And this is what that's
going to look like.
After covering the
financial comparison,
there will be a couple
of slides talking
about the high-level next steps.
And this is intended to lead
into the next conversation
for an advance service.
TAD EINSTEIN: Thanks so
much for that demo, Karl--
really impressive.
And with that being
said, I just wanted
to recall for everyone who's
watching that you can also
do exactly what Karl just did in
a full hands-on lab environment
prior to deploying StratoZone
within your environment.
To do so and take the
Introduction to StratoZone
Assessments hands-on lab,
follow the first link
to register for access to Google
Cloud Learning's platforms
and then click on
the following link
so that you can start the
lab and actually leverage
StratoZone within a real
world hands-on lab environment
prior to actually deploying it
in your enterprise environment.
With that being said, Karl
and I would both to thank you
for your time.
We look forward to seeing
you on Google Cloud.
And we hope you really enjoy
the benefits that StratoZone
will bring to your business.
Thank you.
KARL KOSHY: Thank you.